i want to talk a little bit about your
personal life if that's cool i think
this is really neat
that your your girlfriend is her name
ebony
yeah her your girlfriend ebony was your
stunt devil or still is your stunt
double
yeah there's two funny things about
ebony she's my stunt double
and we look nothing alike we're just
like the same complexion
um and she's white which is really funny
when we go out to eat
because she'll put down her card
and people will assume that i've paid
because i look like my name is ebony
you know what i never get i never get
that i never get that
no one ever is like and you're ebony uh
no conan yeah you know i don't get that
it's asian and white and they're like
there's no way that
this one is ebony we're gonna go with
that one yeah
well uh she's beautiful we got she's
beautiful you guys are a gorgeous couple
i hate how big the photo is i do you
know what's sick
i've had this photo for a while
i i carry i just have this around and
every now and then i'm just like
yeah they're beautiful yeah yeah thanks
bill
yeah that doesn't look that's not a good
look for me to get like get pulled over
and they're like what are you doing with
this
i think that's a very great that's your
support for the lgbtqia plus
totally yes thank you thank you i'm
going to have this only
no it's it's uh she is absolutely
uh beautiful and i'm told that she is
quite handy around the house that she's
yeah
she does everything around here she
obviously like i just said pace for
dinner so there's that um
she has been building making me day beds
uh really she can build stuff yeah
we have like a breakfast nook now she
just took up carpentry during covid
which is wild because i took up nothing
um no who does that who takes it she
sounds like a
superhero i mean to take up carpentry
during coven and be like okay i'm gonna
build you a breakfast nook
yeah and we never even eat breakfast
there so
i'm a [ __ ] bag can i say [ __ ]
yes that's okay yes you can that's all
right
i'm asking the sensors right now in
nigeria and they're saying it's gone
right what are the rules in nigeria very
different they don't mind that word but
they're they get very upset about other
words so
yeah um now is uh so
if ebony is pretty much a carpenter now
mm-hmm yeah whatever do you give her
like gifts
do you give her i got her a table saw um
and bought her a bunch of wood so that
she can make my stuff
so that's what you do in partnerships
right you like
get them guess what i've been married
for 18 years my wife never given me a
table saw or any kind of tool because
she knows i'm an idiot
and i i can't use it yeah i mean she
knows your strengths and weaknesses at
this point
so fair enough is it
is this true that um i i was told that
you gave
your girlfriend a cardboard cutout of
yourself
uh that sounds like the most
egotistical thing i've ever heard and a
great idea
hey i was when we were doing long
distance and so
i was gonna send her a cardboard cutout
of like
you know her celebrity crush or
something
um and i was seeing my friends on
amazon as cardboard cutouts and i was
like maybe i
am on here and so i was
which is so wild that's great yeah
yeah so i ordered her a cardboard cut
out of myself and
i mean that's like romance yes well also
it's a sign that you've really made it
when you can go on amazon and they
already have a cardboard cut out of you
kiersey clements ready to go that means
you've made it dog
hello